that's probably not a great motivation
yeah well prostitution's legal in new
york now
so there are well there's there's always
that yes
yes 100 and there's pornography you know
where you don't have to speak at all
i guess i guess i wonder if it's like um
it's too
i have i should tell you the people who
are listening i have a list on my
website of great books there's like
100 i swear to god i thought you were
about to say i have a list of great
pornography
and i
anyways i have a list of great books on
my website and i put that there because
these are books that had a major impact
on me
both as a scientific thinker but also as
a philosophical or psychological thinker
so i'd encourage people if you want to
facil if you want to develop your
capacity to articulate yourself and
gain all the advantages that that brings
along with it which are immense
in every possible sphere of life you
could go read those books
and you won't come out of that knowing
everything but you'll come out of it
knowing a lot more than you did when you
went in
and then you're deadly regardless of
what you do do do you think that um
a liberal arts education or humanities
education is too derivative from
making money no no no no no
when it's proper not at all exactly and
the evidence suggests that it's not look
in the eyes of the public i'm saying in
the eyes of the public yeah but
look look what rich people do with their
kids historically
they send them to get a liberal arts
education well do you think it's because
they're stupid
that's not why they did that they know
that there isn't anything that makes
you more powerful than being literate
and articulate yeah and so you might say
well you didn't get trained in anything
specific and maybe you need to buttress
your liberal arts degree
with training in something specific but
being able to communicate especially as
you rise up the ranks in any
organization
there isn't anything that serves you
better than your ability to communicate
i mean you read to learn you communicate
to negotiate
to plan to strategize to encourage other
people to bring them on board to
put them on your side it's like so if
you're
if you have finesse with language
nothing can possibly stand in your way
and that's how it should be taught to
young especially young men but not only
young men but especially young men it's
like
you want to get somewhere like learn to
speak
yeah yeah yeah yeah in its most
basic sense do you want to get somewhere
learn how to speak
you